conventionally speaking aggro is a
fairly straightforward archetype your
opponent is at a life total the rules of
the game so you need to turn that life
total to zero you try to do so as
quickly as possible common ways of doing
this consist of direct damage small
creatures large creatures rushed out
quickly and so forth red deck wins is
instructive here a mixture of burn
smells and small creatures means that
the aggro player will try to deal as
much creature damage as possible early
then hope that they can run the deck to
the finish line with burn in a 20 Health
format this is straightforward and makes
sense what about in Commander though
that 12 120 Health format we all know
and love a mere 39 lightning bolts are
needed presuming each player got shots
thems with a land or 39 Swings with a
Delver of Secrets if you prefer or 13
Swings with an Elite Squad of three
delvers of
secret
perplexing the answer is that it doesn't
work the fact that EDH is a 40 life
format is a paino for our hypothetical
red deck winner with this in mind I
think an instructive exercise is to
think about what 40 life really
means first of all life pay is so much
less punishing fetches and shocks easy
forx Mana symbols close enough to free
paying one life for one card an even
more delicious bargain than usual these
effects worthwhile but noticeably
painful in a 20 Health format are now
nearly painless
secondly blocking isn't as necessary Dex
are empowered to constantly use tap
abilities to swing in for value with a
Biden ofasa effect and to eat 5 to 10
damage hits rather than blocking with an
important creature they're also
empowered to spend their early turns
throwing down snowbally value cards
rather than committing much to
board so with that stuff in mind what
happens if you remove that extra health
and take away those things suddenly that
perex arena is a liability that
dismember is close to regaining its
status as a three Mana Black Card your
commander might need to be a blocker if
you didn't add enough creatures to your
deck and trading is the best case
scenario spending a turn playing setup
cards for an approaching big turn goes
from an exciting proposition to a
terrifying one when you might be the one
to get knocked out if you skimp on
blockers your hands are tied your knees
are quivering and your deck was
decidedly not built for this
situation to me this is the best
starting point for looking at EDH Agro
your goal doesn't start and end with
reducing your opponent's life to to zero
like it generally does in 20 Health 1v1
formats because cutting out a large
chunk of an opponent's life total is
helpful in its own right my Mantra in a
game where somebody has a deck that is
concerning and unpredictable but not
necessarily totally dominant is that
they should be at 15 life when somebody
is at 15 life they have to play much
more conservatively having safe setup
turns isn't a given and they're
generally one round of attacks away from
Death if they start doing concerning
things going forward I'm going to refer
to this concept as aggro
ideology this is not the beginning and
the end of what aggro means in EDH but
simply a phrase I use to gesture at the
benefits of having opponents who are
scared about their life total if I had
to pick out a second feature of the
commander format that's important for
aggro decks it's Commander damage if
your commander deals 21 combat damage to
an opponent they lose this means that if
your deck is Commander based you're
playing a 21 Health format instead of
the much more challenging 40 Health
format neat now Agro ideology and
Commander damage aren't mutually
exclusive nor do you need both for a
summary of what decks care about what
things this is a handy
diagram outside the circles we have
Decks that lose there may be effective
aggro Decks that don't use Commander
damage and don't take advantage of
disrupted opponents but they are
exceedingly rare on the right here we
have pure Voltron this is a deck that
plays a commander Buffs it and protects
it through a combination of other cards
and kills players very quickly in large
bursts of damage the higher level in
aggr list is the more Voltron it will be
generally speaking in the middle here is
pseudo Voltron these decks will commonly
utilize Commander damage to win but will
often have other forms of damage as well
this gives the deck multiple win plans
as well as allowing for both focused
kills and general table Beatdown which
may have different use cases depending
on what you're playing against the last
type of deck here is disruptive aggro
this is a deck that fully commits to the
plan of making its opponents
uncomfortable you'll commonly see lots
of cards that damage multiple opponents
often paired with some form of stacks
I've included links to examples of each
of these types of decks in the
description now that I've laid out a
conceptual foundation for aggro let's
talk about the specific goals and
challenges that are important within a
game for a creature-based aggro deck the
basic idea is simple you want creatures
on board and you want them to connect
with your opponent's life totals to
connect with life totals you need to get
past blockers the most common way of
going about this is evasion either
innately on the aggressive creatures or
applied through equipments or cards such
as Wonder an alternative method is
eliminating those blockers but this is
much less common one example is a budget
Rose discard deck I built that runs
malagor as the commander mostly as a way
of clearing out
blockers maintaining creatures on board
is a separate challenge with the
roadblock there you being board wipes
there's no one foolproof solution to
this but here are some potential
workarounds for one be faster than the
deck with the board wipes and Target
them first this is likely the preferred
method for higher power Voltron
decks alternatively run protection
spells permanent base is preferable for
an aggro Deck with selfless spirit being
the absolute gold standard if you're
running white you can also run instance
that protect your creatures or even
counter spells but keep in mind that
holding up mana will make your deck less
Mana efficient and unless you have
Treasures or unless you have creatures
with flash as a third option run blood
artist effects this is my preferred
strategy when playing black as it ties
in beautifully with our aggro
ideology the point about outrunning
board wipes ties into a broader point
about the speed of a deck speed and
resilience are factors that need to be
considered a deck that can outrun most
Combos and kill mid-range before it
stabilizes might not need much in the
way of counter plays or resistance to
obstacles but a slower deck might want a
lot more of these things
however putting those things in a deck
also tends to slow it down more so it's
a balancing act my liasa hate Bears deck
is a good example of a slower more
resilient aggro deck that is constantly
chewing on life totals but whose
reliably brutal commander and high
density of stacks mean it doesn't
necessarily need to win super
early past the basics a key skill you'll
want to develop is Target
prioritization if your deck prefers to
kill one player at a time you need to
pick a player to focus and picking wrong
might lose you the game primary targets
that come to mind are players who pay a
lot of life and players who have
especially strong ways to shut you down
but it's definitely a Vibes based thing
and when in doubt you can just attack
the opponent you're most afraid of a
final challenge I'll mention is that at
some tables aggro is considered rude in
some capacity this is especially common
in pods populated with fiddly mid-range
decks where knocking out a player early
means they'll spend upwards of an hour
sitting on the sidelines these
environments are not my preferred one to
play in but ultimately they simply stem
from the fact that EDH is a social game
played in a lot of different ways the
kitty gloves fiddly version of it is one
way it's played but you can certainly
try to smack a little variety into your
playgroup with a Beatdown deck